c'est valérie
[Musique]
c'est bien peu ces collisions
intellection autour de toi autour de la
table points qui le plus stylé qui est
le moins stylé qui fait vraiment
attention à lui à son allure tard c'est
mathieu lemoine style je dirais gilles
où il n'y avait jamais de faute de
fausses notes qu'il faudrait lui mettre
plein de fantaisie parce que je suis
sûre ça le rendrait le nouveau look de
série moi je les préfère là quand il est
en costume trois pièces
sauf que c'est hyper élégant la petite
raie sur le côté la barbe bien taillée
terrasser un petit côté un hipster de de
tunisie qui est pas mal du tout
[Musique]
une galette abbas et mousse aux amis
d'henri son âge il y aurait 8 bis oui
c'est un garçon que je j'aurai battu
aurait pu mal à m'attirer own et moi au
bout de la terre d'un même film charlie
st
justin timberlake avec snoop dogg mardi
dix mois sans la boxe que ça donne un
côté un bloc musique on s'est dit on
n'est pas dans ce métier des vaches mais
dans la bouche tout à fait pas du fait
des vannes pourries voilà tu désires tu
ne dois pas rire et en a combien l'a13
gens qu'un chien qui s'appelle wouah ils
le mangent le soir même que fait-il
appel festin by chihuahua
un mexique a fait la vaisselle il dit
quoi
aïe c'est sale ça c'est une femme qui
prend son pain son chien pet
elle se noie pourquoi parce que son cher
c'est un pékinois trois cloîtres aller
bouffer le dernier truc que tu as fait
avec la bande de chroniqueurs en dehors
de l'antenne et avec qui c'est le
lancement de ma collection capsule
donc j'ai fait une petite soirée et j'ai
invité toutes les filles avec quelques
chroniqueurs pourrais-tu partir en road
trip au géraldine direct à traiter de
quelques chroniqueurs préfères-tu être
assise à l'antenne pourquoi j'adore être
assise à côté de benjamin tippett qui
pourrait ne pas le dire parce qu'il ne
fait pas de bruit qu'ils ne déposeront
les garçons un malin plaisir à tous et
la bombe où j'ai travaillé du coup
maintenant qu'aux alors que c'était très
sympa ces petits moments merci monsieur
merci valérie salut
moi je suis prévenu que si j'ai pas
jamar toujours un peu les